del lujo estamos en el problema 16 y es
el último problema de este examen 4 de
la sección 8 del examen 4 pero es el
último del examen 4 después de este
problema en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
empezar el examen 5 así que estoy
bastante emocionado y de una vez
ataquemos el problema seguramente va a
ser un vídeo muy corto porque solamente
nos falta un problema y dice después del
primer término cada término siguiente de
esta sucesión es tres unidades más
grandes que un tercio el término
anterior y esto habla de sucesiones y
dice que si nosotros tenemos el primer
término después de este primer término
cualquier término siguiente es tres
unidades más grande que un tercio el
término anterior vamos a ver si eso lo
podemos escribir
si tengo el término a se me ocurre el
término n entonces el término n lo
podemos ver como un tercio un tercio el
término anterior
tercio el término n 1 aquí es justo lo
que me dicen es más grande que un tercio
del término anterior ya esto le sumamos
tres unidades ya esto hay que sumarle
tres unidades es decir que así podemos
visualizar cualquier término de esta
asociación que no sea el término inicial
ok
perfecto y después que dice si te es el
primer número de esta sucesión y te es
distinto de cero a esto es importante
que es distinto de 0 10 el primer
término de esta sucesión
entonces el primer término éste como se
vería el segundo término bueno pues
aplicando esta fórmula el segundo
término sería un tercio de tm más 3 un
tercio del término anterior más 3 un
tercio del término anterior que esté un
tercio de t
3 y así podremos seguir sacando términos
y términos y términos y términos de esta
sucesión pero esperemos un poco dice sí
que es el primer término de esta
sucesión y t es distinto de 0 cuál es la
proporción del segundo término comparado
con el primer término cuál es la razón
en la proporción del segundo término
comparado con el primero es decir que
esencialmente lo que nos preguntan es
cuánto vale
lo voy a poner aquí cuánto vale el
término 2 a comparación del término 1
cuál es la razón o la proporción de esto
y bueno aquí tengo el término 2 aquí
tengo el término 1 que te parece si lo
sustituimos me va a quedar que esto es
lo mismo que un tercio dt más 3 esto
entre te y esto es exactamente lo mismo
que a un tercio un tercio más 3 entre t
lo que hice fue dividir este entre este
ok y este entre este ya está esta es la
respuesta a mi problema un tercio más 3
entre t y no está un tercio más 3 ya ya
ya ya veo qué es lo que tenemos que
hacer fíjate bien voy a cambiar al color
salmón lo que tenemos que hacer es dada
esta expresión a encontrar encontrar el
denominador común verlo como una
expresión conjunta en lugar de tener una
suma de quebrados vamos a encontrar el
denominador común y el denominador común
entre 3 y t pues es 3 t3 este y decimos
3 de entre 3 es lo mismo que te por una
este ok
3 t entre t es lo mismo que tres por
tres es nueve temas nueve entre tres
temas nueve entre entre este tema 9 este
es el inciso c perfecto entonces ya está
esta resolución del problema lo único
que tenemos que hacer era dividir el
segundo término entre el primer término
y bueno yo creo que lo más difícil de
este problema no era tanto la división
sino llegar a este resultado y decir oh
no no están las respuestas que podemos
hacer y darnos cuenta que lo único que
nos faltaba era escribirlo como un
término común para encontrarlo así en
nuestras respuestas es decir no hay que
perder la calma
muy bien pues este fue el último
problema del examen número 4 de la
sección número 8 y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo donde hablaremos del
siguiente examen del examen número 5 el
siguiente vídeo del siguiente examen y
hasta la próxima
nos vemos pronto